- Welcome back everybody.
I'm hanging out with Jenna Lyons.
Give it up!
(audience cheers and applauds)
So next year, athletes
from around the world
will gather in Paris
for the 2024 Olympics.
My next guest is a retired
Olympian and world champion
and fencing.
She's training the next
generation of Olympic hopefuls,
but that's only part of her story.
More impressive, she's
providing mentorship
and leadership to underserved kids
right here in New York City.
Please welcome Nzingha Prescod everybody.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Meet Jenna.
- Hi!
- I'm so glad you're here.
- Yeah, thank you.
- So, we didn't plan this,
but you fenced as well.
You fenced in high school, right?
- I fenced in, I mean I
fenced in high school.
Let's, between.
- I know, but I didn't even know
what fencing really was in high school.
Like, it wasn't like a thing,
like an opportunity for me as a kid.
I never even knew about it.
So I find that incredible
that you both did that.
- I went to for like
a heartbeat, a little,
a private French school
and then I transferred out.
But they were very into
fencing and I liked the outfit.
- Yeah, it's pretty chique.
- [Jenna] It's very chique.
- But you grew up fencing, right?
- I did grow up fencing.
So I grew up in Brooklyn.
I grew up in an area of
Brooklyn called Flatlands,
which is right outside of Flatbush,
predominantly Caribbean.
My mom raised my sister and I,
and she always put us in a lot of sports.
She's very socially conscious
and really believes in black excellence.
And so she learned about Peter Westbrook,
who is a six time Olympian
and bronze medalist at 1984.
And so he was sending a
lot of inner city youth
to the Olympics and so
she was like, "Perfect!
"I'm gonna send my girls there."
And so we commuted from Flatlands,
which is in Outer Brooklyn,
all the way up to Chelsea, Manhattan.
And as I was getting good, it
was four or five times a week.
So it was quite a commitment.
It was pretty successful.
- You have super mom.
- I have a super mom.
- Yeah.
- Bless my mommy.
She is so great.
- Yeah.
And you said she's a single mama?
- She's a single mom.
- Oh my gosh,
holding all that down
and taking you to all
those things, that's a lot.
- Right, and from there
I was able to work with the Olympic coach
since I was 10.
And that allowed me to win
world championship medals,
go to two Olympics,
and have a really
phenomenal fencing career.
Next year I'll be in the Hall of Fame,
so that's pretty awesome.
- Oh my gosh!
Congratulations!
(audience cheers and applauds)
That's incredible.
- Yeah.
An incredible journey.
Fencing has really changed my life a ton
and enabled a lot of opportunities.
So it's--
- And it builds, I think for
kids, when you find something,
I always say this on the show,
but when you find something you're good at
and you feel good about and special,
it gives you a different
level of confidence.
- Confidence, right?
- Yeah.
- And that you can do, can do, can do.
Yeah, and you take that
with you everywhere, so.
- Yeah.
- That's been--
- It totally transfers over
in other parts of your life.
I agree.
So explain fencing 'cause I had to do it,
like I said for "The Voice"
one time, and I was like,
"I'm sorry, what?
"You want me to what?"
You know, explain that if nobody
had ever like heard of it,
which a lot of people haven't, like--
- It's incredibly technical.
It's, people call it athletic chess.
- It is, yeah.
- Right, it's very physical.
But even more so than
physical, it's very mental.
- It's like strategy.
- Right, it's totally critical thinking,
analyzing, problem solving.
So there's like this maze
that you're constantly trying
to figure out the intricacies
of how to change this
detail or that detail
so that you can battle your opponent
and come out victorious.
So it's a really amazing,
well-rounded sport.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It normally attracts a
lot of affluent people.
Prep schools, Ivy League schools.
- That's why I never heard
of it when I was young, yeah.
- So, like, it allowed
me to go to Columbia,
fence on Columbia's team.
And just opens a lot of doors.
And so you can imagine
it's quite expensive.
And so that makes it pretty exclusionary
in terms of geography, finances,
even culturally, it's pretty hard
to immerse a community in fencing
when historically it's been
a predominantly white sport.
So that's the background.
- Yeah, that's like a rich
people sport where I'm like,
they were like, "Yeah, I played polo."
I'm like, "Okay, I played
volleyball," I was like,
I don't like all the public
school things you do.
Well explain your organization.
Like why is this important to you?
- Right, so I grew up
with this opportunity,
but I was an anomaly in accessing that.
And so I started the Prescott Institute
for Sport Teamwork and Education.
We started as fencing in the park,
which is a summer program.
And so we just, I wanted to
increase access to the sport
in my community where I grew up
because I did have that huge
kind of burden of traveling.
And so I always wanted to bring it back
with all this skill I
acquired over 20 plus years
and open up those doors for
the youth in my community.
- The kid that was you, yeah.
- Yes, for the kids that were me,
because I was the only one
growing up who had that.
And even just quality, organized
sports are very expensive.
And where I grew up, it's not accessible.
And so that was just always
something I wanted to bring back
and put in my neighborhood
so that breaking down all those barriers
for the next generation.
- And it gives you confidence,
but it also, it keeps kids out of trouble.
That's why my mom, you know,
I was always in sports,
I was always in theater.
I was always involved in something
and that's why I stayed outta trouble.
- Idle hands, yeah.
- Idle hands, right.
And it's productive outlet for them.
It's productive.
You learn strong work ethic.
I always tell people I had
to learn how to work hard.
So that's what we teach them.
We teach them to have strong characters,
to be good leaders, to be good people.
So we heavily instill
Olympic values of excellence,
friendship, and respect in the program.
And just hope they'll use
it in their next steps
and whatever--
- They will
and they won't even know they're doing it.
There are things that I was
so annoyed by when I was a kid
and I was like, "Ugh! Why
do I have to do this?"
And then now I'd see it in my work ethic.
You know, you didn't really
see it when you were a kid.
- It pays it forward.
- Yeah, agreed.
- Right.
- All right.
Joining us now are Julia and Amy,
two of Nzingha fencing students
from her non-profit school in Brooklyn.
Welcome to the show, ladies.
- Hi!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- So I have to ask,
what's your favorite part of fencing?
- My favorite part of fencing
is that I make lots of friends
and we go through things
and once I beat my brother,
he was a little bit mad.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God, you're just like my kids.
That's amazing.
I love the competition.
What about you?
- My favorite part of fencing
is the fact that I get to work
with kids that can relate to,
and it helps me balance being in a school
and being an athlete.
- Yeah, I love that too.
(audience applauds)
Like those relationships.
So I have to ask you this,
I wanted to ask a minute ago,
but how do you afford the non-profit?
Like how do you do this?
Like, it's a lot of money.
- Right, so the program
is free for families.
So equipment, lessons, classes,
all of our services for families are free.
So we depend on funders.
Individual funders,
we get some funding from the City Council.
So very thankful.
Some corporate sponsors.
So I'm an employee at Ernst and Young, EY,
so they've been very
supportive of the program,
allowing me to work
full-time on building it.
And then Ballet's Corporation
has been super helpful.
And then non-profits,
like Women's Sport Foundation
has been really incredible.
We're actually going
to be there later today
to accept an award.
So it's really community effort where
it's been very active and
the team's very active
to find funding and so we're
not yet going national,
but hopefully this year
we'll go to the nationals.
And then from there
it's international, so.
- It's the only thing
holding you back really
the financial part of it
when you say nationals--
- Right, financials are
like, we all work very hard.
- I was the kid that went on scholarship
to anything in high school like
'cause we didn't have money.
So this matters.
- It really matters.
- And it really does change
a person's trajectory
like their life.
- Right, exactly.
So we're trying to give them the best
and they deserve the best, so.
- Absolutely.
- We depend on the community.
- All right, well I was thinking,
Amy, you want to teach us
like a move or something?
I mean, the swords here,
I'm here, you're here.
- Of course.
- Okay, let's do it.
Okay, let's stand up.
(audience cheers and applauds)
You want to do it?
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- I heard there's a specific way
we're supposed to get a sword.
Is that right?
- Well, first things first,
you can never have the
tip be in the air, right.
- Okay.
- 'Cause that's a safety hazard.
So you wanna keep your tip down.
And I think Amy knows how
to hold the foil pretty well
so she can show you.
- Okay.
- Do you want to show us, en garde?
- Okay, so we're gonna
do the advanced lunge.
So I'm going to put my foot forward
and then bring my other foot.
Then we put the pressure on
my other foot and we lunge.
- Ooh, looks like a workout, Amy.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
- In heels.
That's a plus.
- That's all right.
That's all right, we're women.
We do it all the time.
So what about, when do I get my sword?
(everyone laughs)
When do I get that?
Are we gonna play with that?
We're not gonna play with that?
Okay, I want one, I want one.
I was like, "Can I have one?"
Do you have to, you grab
it a certain way, right?
- Yes, I'll grab one, yes.
- Okay.
- So grab it by.
- So it's facing down.
- This is called a pommel.
- Well, I'm the host.
I have to hand them out.
Yeah, I was like, "Here you go.
"There you go."
- Oh, thank you, miss.
- I'm a good host.
(audience laughs)
- I'll grab one too.
- Okay.
- Okay, okay.
Okay, so you stand like this, right?
And your foot is is perpendicular?
Okay.
- Yes.
But you have to bend your knee.
- Oh, sure, okay.
- Ooh! Kelly, that looks good.
- Seems like a workout.
And then you just lunge?
- You advance with one foot,
you put that forward, and then you lunge.
- And then you lunge.
Whoo!
- Ooh, nice.
- I feel like I'm in "Count
of Monte Cristo", I like it.
I like it.
- Good job.
- This is powerful.
I know why y'all like this.
Just having it in my hand alone,
I feel really good about it.
Well, I heard that Julie,
you have something you
wanted say to Nzingha, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Aw!
- I'd like to say that I love you so much
and I thank you for
everything you've done.
- Oh, I love you too.
(audience applauds)
- It's really cool what
you're doing for these kids.
It is really cool.
I wasn't, that's not just lip service.
Literally people that
helped with scholarships
and helped me, give me opportunity
is the reason why I'm here.
So, we actually have something
for you, I love that.
So we actually have something for you.
So Radical Fencing is an NYC based
fencing sport equipment company,
bringing beautifully crafted products
and innovative designs to fencing
to continue supporting peace there,
donating a $5,000 gift
card just to help out
with all the equipment.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We love what you're doing.
Thank you for teaching me.
- You're welcome.
- I can now advance.
I like it.
Look at you.
You were like, "I'm ready girl."
I think it's time for a battle.
- En garde!
- She was automatic.
She was like, "What?"
(audience and Kelly laughs)
Before we go, I want to give
a quick shout out to Maria,
our assistant associate producer
who brought us this story.
She's actually one of
newest members as well
as a fencer herself.
I found out in a meeting.
So she helps volunteer with peace.
Great job, Maria.
We love you.
- Yeah, Kelly, thank you.
- I love finding this out about you.